i'm in the olympics
hello everybody my name is markiplier
what hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to troll
face quest this time number four
sequel to one two and three but knowing
this game they probably don't add up to
four
that adds up to six i had to think about
that but welcome back anyway we're gonna
play this game and it's gonna be a lot
of fun
supposedly hello are you gonna dick me
over
why was that funny to me
oh man i spit on my own nose how did i
do that hi
wow hey i did good
oh man this is how this usually goes it
makes me feel good about doing things in
the beginning
hmm i missed well how did i do that
um maybe i need to move it closer
hey hey i'm like a genius
more like i know how this game operates
hey you snowman [ __ ] you think you got
a fence with me
i am an expert well [ __ ] i don't think
that's how you fence
okay ow yes stumpy arm bastard
well this ain't going good wait what is
this
hi oh hey how's
how's it going oh no it's the sun
i didn't know it was sun it had a giant
face on it that's usually associated
with the moon
okay hi oh are you gonna crush me again
ow one finger punch
or one inch it wasn't one it was his
whole fist trust me
i know the difference between a finger
and a fist personal experience
not like that oh boy
what oh okay
okay okay drill a hole in that ice it's
a smart decision do it right as you're
standing on go go go
gotta go fast gotta go fast gotta go
sonic fast
oh uh
uh
yay how did that do anything at all
did i win or did i influence it okay go
go go
go go go ah you're dead ain't that so
sad everyone's gonna mourn your loss
but what if i click it i could have
clicked oh i know what i need to do
ha ha oh [ __ ] hang on keep dying a few
more times i'm gonna get this
right eventually damn it there's a way
to click oh [ __ ] no i don't need the
walk through
not now i'm still good at games
whoa hey i just held the mouse down i
guess that's good and things world
record go
ah everyone's laughing at me
huh oh what [ __ ] stop that
and it's
gonna work
i gotta really use my motor finger
skills
this ain't doing [ __ ] okay ah
just tell me the stupid way you want me
to succeed so that i can move on
everyone's so bored or happy or angry at
me
whoa okay
hey i did it okay damn i just have to
he'll hold the hell whoa here
i just got to hold things down and i i
i'm not used to that
wait ah wait no
put that put that put that away
put put that away put put that away
put hood hood
this isn't shot hey
oh i got it put it over there
why over there that didn't make any
sense i was putting it everywhere
oh what
that's that's what i wanted to do but i
didn't know how to do it
god damn it
yes put that down doping are you selling
drugs mister
hey wait
oh ah
well
so one of these is the right one
oh uh huh
oh come on what a bunch of baloney i did
everything oh there's one mind is hat
okay i gotcha
oh thank you for the boobs oh just what
i've always dreamed of
boobs okay i've maxed out my new rpg
character
i'm ready to play final fantasy what the
[ __ ] am i doing
how about you eat one of these you oh oh
i just needed to click on me oh hey here
i was stupid overthinking things
huh wow i think your head just got cut
clean off there bruh
bruh oh
the crowd's cheering for me for once my
god they
love me oh now they're
sad and quiet oh that's the usual thing
oh hey
what what the hell happened okay
how's this gonna be terrible
and they're quiet
all right there buddy you calm down
there we got a long day ahead of us
so there was something to this cheering
and him doing the thing
okay so cheering made him
damn it
oh beautiful and only a six from the
russian judge
that joke is older than i am oh boy what
are you doing are you gonna mug me
why are you standing there so close when
i have a gun
this is the new crowd cheering him on he
can almost hear it through those goggles
or earmuffs either one
uh
limbo
i don't know what she wants limbo
he won't he won't lambo he won't loan me
i don't know how oh hey
hey hey there we go oh yeah
all right i don't know why that worked
and i don't know why i liked it
was this hi
how is that better wizard come back
wizard i don't think the wizard's coming
back
how is this better oh that's how oh much
better i'm so happy now
and i'm sure they're happy together in
their life
why why was that inflating my penis and
why did inflating my penis cause my
muscles to grow
and why did you reveal my secret to my
bulking muscles to everybody on the
internet i thought we
had a deal here troll face game
porpoise porpoise fork motorshork
[ __ ] we sank
i guess we won by murdering everyone
else so that just shows you kids if you
want to succeed in life
actually don't take this next piece of
advice god no you know i was gonna say
please dear god don't do that
what the hell is this
yay we're dead great
okay it was that easy here i thought
death was inevitable
oh no poor me he inflated his penis too
much
there's no way you could have beat that
guy probably
oh oh oh
oh all right and no one else
seems to be upset by that i guess we're
good these olympics are awesome
oh oh he died well i wanted to encourage
him
instead he failed that's my life
what is this go man go
oh he died i tried to hit him with a
stick and he didn't succeed
why oh
oh i thought he was gonna carry the
torch i didn't know i'd light him on
fire that good enough for me what does
this do
wait so i'm trying to put this out why
am i trying to do that why am i trying
to sabotage the olympics
do you like that ladies the mixture of
my meticulous fingers and this guy
thrown up
pretty cool huh
oh oh hey your magic sneeze that made me
hit my target in the fire go out
all right well i won but i seem sad now
oh i get it i'm smug in my victory
because the troll is now decrepit and
sad and an alcoholic great so that's
succeeding in life i guess win the
olympics and make everyone sadder than
you
that's the life lesson to learn from
markiplier today hope you enjoyed your
learning today with markiplier life
lesson learning channel
thanks again everybody for watching hope
it didn't waste your time
and as always i will see you in the next
video
ain't no problem ain't nobody gonna stop
the boogie bus humping